this video is brought to you by keeps
did you know that two out of every three
guys are going to experience some form
of male pattern ball despite the time
they're 35.
yeah i did and now you do too i wish
keeps have been around when i was
younger because there have been
advancements in science so now there are
treatments that can combat the symptoms
of hair loss and help you keep the hair
that you have like it's too late for me
i'm already fully bald my hair is not
coming back but you don't have to be
like me you can stop your hair loss
early thanks to keeps keeps offers
generic versions of the only two fda
approved drugs for treating hair loss so
you might have tried them before but
never at a price this low that's right
if you were thinking oh this is going to
be medicine this is medicine it's going
to be really expensive don't worry it's
not keep start to just 10 a month how
does it work well for one thing no need
to visit a doctor just schedule a quick
online consult bit later discreet
package will arrive at your door and you
can use it in the privacy of your own
home so if you're noticing that you're
losing your hair it's not a problem it's
gonna solve itself do something about it
for a limited time go to keeps.com
forward slash biographics or click the
link in the description below to receive
fifty percent off your first order and
now back to the video
matthias was the first african-american
to become a successful arctic explorer
not only that but according to some
accounts he may be the first person to
reach the north pole even so henson
rarely received credit from his
contemporaries for his achievement as
most people preferred to praise robert
peary who's better suited to their ideal
image of an american explorer but
inevitably the pendulum swings the other
way it might have taken decades but the
world finally began to recognize that
matthew henson was one of the greatest
explorers in american history he was
awarded medals and honorary doctorates
he was put on a stamp and had parks
schools and even a glacier named after
him he was also re-buried at arlington
national cemetery matthew henson is no
longer simply an asterisk in somebody
else's career
[Music]
matthew alexander henson was born
shortly after the end of the american
civil war on august 8 1866 in nanjimo
maryland even before the abolition of
slavery his parents had been free black
americans who made a modest living a
sharecroppers despite their freed status
they still had to contend with racist
vitriol and terror attacks from the ku
klux klan and other white supremacists
who began lashing out more frequently
after the confederacy lost the civil war
in an attempt to find a safer
environment for their children the
henson parents left nand muay and moved
further up north to a town called
georgetown near washington dc
unfortunately both parents died in the
years that followed and while still a
young boy matthew henson found himself
an orphan in the care of his uncle there
was one event in henson's childhood that
he later described as having a profound
inspiring effect on him when he was 10
years old he attended a ceremony to
honor abraham lincoln one of the keynote
speakers was frederick douglass the
former slave who became a prominent
author social reformer and statesman in
his speech douglas urged young black
people to seek an education in order to
combat racial prejudices and inequality
with these words in his heart when he
was barely 12 years old hanson made his
way to baltimore maryland which was
steadily developing into a thriving poor
town he found a job in 1878 as a cabin
boy aboard a three-masted merchant ship
called the katie hines under the command
of captain charles henson spent the next
six years of his life on that vessel
captain charles took the uncabin boy
under his wing and provided him with an
education besides learning how to read
and write henson also became an adept
sailor and trained in a variety of
skills such as navigation and sailing
that would later prove useful in his
career as an explorer by the time he
turned 20 matthew henson was a salty sea
dog who had traveled to the far east
north africa and the arctic seas captain
charles passed away in 1887 prompting
henson to leave the katie hines and find
a new vocation in life the adventure bug
had bitten him but he did not have the
means to go gallivanting to far away
lands on his own and so he went to
washington dc and took a safe but boring
job as a clerk for a furrier's shop but
that didn't last long
henson's life changed forever one day in
november 1887 when a navy officer came
looking to sell walrus and seal pelts
brought from greenland he was robert
peary an engineer and explorer who had
already made up his mind to become the
first man to reach the north pole at
that point in time period just returned
from his first expedition into the
arctic and had every intention of going
back however he was still an active
member of the united states navy corps
of civil engineers so he couldn't just
leave when he felt like it instead he
was due to travel to nicaragua to
conduct some surveys on possible routes
for the proposed nicaraguan canal which
as we know today was never built while
in the furious shop peri and henson got
to talking the officer learned of
henson's exploits at sea and was
impressed with his nautical experience
especially given the fact that just a
few years prior the clerk was a poor
orphan who couldn't read or write piri
recognized potential when he saw it so
he offered henson a position as his aide
for his upcoming surveying expedition to
nicaragua matthew henson had developed a
strong hankering for adventure so such
an opportunity was too good for him to
pass up he accepted the offer and
although neither of them knew it yet
began a partnership that would literally
take them to the ends of the earth the
following year matthiensen found himself
in the rainforests of central america as
a personal assistant to peery over the
next two years it was live henson helped
the officer create a map of nicaragua's
tropical forests in search of possible
routes for the canal the former cabin
boy performed admirably during the trip
and returned to the united states as one
of piri's good friends he even helped
henson find a job as a messenger for the
league island naval yard in philadelphia
but hanson already knew our life pushing
pencils behind the desk was not for him
instead he dreamt about going on
adventures again exploring the untamed
lands of the world indeed it didn't take
long for such an occasion to arise by
1891 henson started building a regular
life for himself he had a steady job was
newly married to a woman named eva flint
however peary had received leave from
the navy as well as financial support
from the american geographical society
to continue his exploration of greenland
he began assembling his team and at the
top of his list was matthew henson who
eagerly accepted to serve once again
[Music]
the north greenland expedition party set
sail from new york in june 1891 aboard
the ss kite at that time much of the
arctic was a mystery so their main
mission was not to attempt to reach the
north pole but simply to explore
greenland and see if it was an
individual land mass or a peninsula as
far as matthiensen was concerned while
he may not have had any formal training
or experience in arctic conditions he
learned by doing he became a jack of all
trades for filling numerous roles during
his multiple trips to the frozen regions
of the north he served as a navigator
map maker hunter fisherman translator
soldierer carpenter and dog handler
unlike most explorers neither peery nor
hansen adopted an i know best attitude
when it came to arctic survival they
recognized the fact that the local inuit
people had tips and tricks to help them
survive in the seemingly never-ending
frozen wastes of the arctic since after
all they were the ones who'd managed to
turn it into their home they learned how
to hunt how to build igloos and even how
to dress in furs even though other
explorers consider the practice
undignified and gentlemanly while piri
was willing to use information from the
inuit to survive his eagerness did not
translate to affection or respect for
them but where piri was horrid and quick
to betray people he considered unworthy
henson was compassionate henson knew
firsthand how it felt to be treated like
a secondhand citizen and he had no
intention of doing the same to others he
showed a genuine interest in inuit
culture and learned their language which
proved to be an invaluable asset when it
came to securing the help for his
expeditions they called him mari parlock
which was roughly translated to matthew
the kind one in turn he wrote in his
memoirs that i've come to love these
people i know every man woman and child
in their tribe they are my friends and
regard me as theirs going back to the
actual expedition itself it accomplished
its goal although not without hardships
and sacrifices the mission was marked by
tragedy when the team's mineralogist
john verhoff lost his life after falling
into a crash the trip took a few months
longer than expected because piri
suffered a leg injury but in the end the
team crossed greenland and proved that
it was in fact one giant island they
made their way back to america in late
1892
[Music]
this had been matthew henson's first
trip to the arctic and it did well to
showcase his skills and tenacity and to
solidify his position as peery's first
man for six more expeditions that they
would undertake together over the coming
17 years the next voyage occurred the
following year this time there were more
men and a bigger ship yet the mission
was a failure due to terrible weather
conditions henson fell ill during this
trip after a long race with death as he
put it and required months of
rehabilitation to get his strength back
on his way back in the summer of 1895
henson swore to never leave his happy
home in warmer lands again but of course
we already know how that one turned out
his oath was about as reliable as that
as someone who promises never to drink
again after
waking up with a raging hangover one
notable thing did happen during that
expedition though henson took in a local
orphan it was on this trip that i
adopted the orphan eskimo boy could look
to his mother having died just previous
to our arrival at the red cliffs after
this boy was washed and scrubbed by me
his long hair cut short and his greasy
dirty clothes of skins and furs burned a
new suit made of odds and ends collected
from different wardrobes on the ship
made him a presentable young american i
was proud of him and he of me he learned
to speak english and slept underneath my
bunk two more missions to greenland
occurred in 1896 and 1897 which resulted
in the team reaching the island's most
northern point and mapping it completely
this was only a secondary objective
though as their main goal was to
retrieve the gargantuan cape york
meteorite that had landed in the frozen
wastes of the arctic the locals weren't
too happy with this though since they
used the metal from the meteorites to
make tools the arctic team's continued
success increased the profile of the
dynamic duo of henson and berry in the
united states that made it easier for
them to secure funds in order to go on
more missions for the next trip they
intended to set a new farthest north
record this is a term that has lost all
value nowadays but before anybody had
reached the north pole arctic explorers
kept setting new records by traveling a
little further each time and the
farthest north referred to the most
northerly latitudes that had been
reached by humanity if we take their
word for it then hanson's team set a new
furthest north on two sequential voyages
to the arctic the first one lasted for
five years between 1898 and 1902. this
time it was perry's turn to suffer the
wrath of the grim destroyer as henson
liked to call the merciless conditions
caused by mother nature in the arctic
wastelands the commander's feet froze so
badly that he lost nine toes frostbite
understandably this injury kept him on
the shelf for a while and henson's team
did not return to the arctic until 1905.
this trip was shorter as they had
obtained a state-of-the-art steamship
dubbed ss roosevelt which was powerful
enough to make its way through the
floating ice packs the climax of this
expedition was one of the rare occasions
when henson was not by the commander's
side as the team got separated earlier
during a storm this actually proved to
be a problem for peery as he didn't have
anyone with him skilled enough in
navigation to confirm that he had set a
new farthest north but they claimed it
anyway and this highlights their big
problem with these expeditions nowadays
robert perry has what we might call an
issue with credibility the guy made a
lot of bold claims and some of them
might not have been true we'll get to
the big one about reaching the north
pole in a minute but his claims of
setting new farthest north records have
also come under scrutiny these doubts
have also tarnished the accomplishments
of matthew henson by association
but enough of the farthest north
malarkey from now on it's north pole or
bust since this was the true goal that
matthew henson and all other arctic
explorers at the time had in mind in
1908 it was finally time for the big one
on july the 6th hanson set off on his
seventh and final arctic mission
alongside his longtime companion this
time determined to make it all the way
to the north pole they first traveled to
greenland where they picked up dozens of
inuit men including cooklatu who was
eager to go exploring alongside his
adoptive father as well as hundreds of
dogs and tons of meat from there they
sailed to ellsmere island in canada
where they made camp and left for the
pole in late february 1909. the simplest
tasks became complicated and exhausting
when they had to be done under the
brutal and relentless conditions at the
arctic even just soldering a few tin
cans became a job for a demon in hades
according to henson worked all day
soldering the tins of alcohol and a very
trying job it was i tried to work with
mittens on i tried to work with them off
as soon as my bare fingers would touch
the cold metal of the tins they would
freeze if i attempted to use my mittens
they would singe and burn and it was
impossible to hold the solder with my
bare skin gloves on when the expedition
started the party consisted of 24 men
but only six were present for the last
leg of the journey matthienson robert
perry and four inuit men six almost
turned to five when matthew henson
slipped on a block of ice and fell into
the icy cold water in the arctic such an
accident could easily have turned into a
death sentence in fact that is exactly
the outcome that befell one of henson's
compatriots professor ross g marvin who
drowned on this expedition while
returning back to camp henson however
did not share his fate as he was saved
by uttar one of the inuit men who
managed to grab the explorer by the name
of the neck just like a sled dog and
pull him out of the water they knew it
stripped hints of his wet clothes and
beat the water out of them then
following a wardrobe change the hunt for
the north pole resumed as if nothing had
ever happened that was when the
commander's nasty side started to show
itself because in that moment honesty
friendship and teamwork didn't matter as
much to him as becoming the first man to
reach the north pole he realized he knew
it weren't going to be a problem and he
would have left henson behind if he had
any chance of making it without him but
he didn't and he knew it matthew hansen
was the one who took care of the dogs
and the supplies he was also the one who
knew how to fix the sledges and he was
the only one who knew how to speak with
he knew it if anything henson was the
one who didn't need peri on april 6 1909
the team made camp for the last time on
their way to the pole up until this
point their camps were simply named camp
number one camp number two etc but they
felt that something special was needed
to mark this momentous occasion
therefore the commander took an american
silk flag and carefully planted it on
top of their igloo christening the
location camp morris k jessup after one
of their financiers the six man went to
sleep and woke up the next morning ready
to make a final march to the north pole
ostensibly the plan was for the faster
henson to scout ahead and then allow the
navy officer to overtake at the last
minute and claim the glory of being the
first to the north pole however henson's
team overshot their target let's say by
mistake but who knows so when perry
finally caught up to them matthienson
greeted him by saying i think i'm the
first man to sit on top of the world
according to henson's journal the mood
became decidedly frosty from that point
on even by arctic standards henson wrote
from the time of my arrival at the
roosevelt for nearly three weeks my days
were spent in complete idleness i would
catch a fleeting glimpse of commander
peri but not once in all that time did
he speak a word to me then he spoke to
me in the most ordinary matter-of-fact
way and ordered me to get to work not a
word about the north pole or anything
connected with it even though neither
one said anything about it they both
knew that the partnership they had had
for over 20 years had disintegrated
[Music]
and piri immediately went to work to
ensure that he was the one who enjoyed
all the fame and glory and not matthew
henson this did not prove difficult
despite his decades of experience and
success racial prejudices against henson
were still pervasive and the world at
large was more than happy to dismiss him
as simply a mere sidekick to the
commander even newspapers of the day
decried the fact that perry gave the
honor of reaching the north pole to a
black man instead of one of his white
companions such as the ship's captain
robert bartlett only other explorers who
knew matthienson personally understood
how indispensable he'd truly been to the
success of the mission and the peri
didn't take him by choice but because he
could not have done it without him even
after he published his own memoir in
1912 titled a negro explorer at the
north pole henson still went mostly
ignored however karma is you know what
and peary encountered a completely
different and unexpected opposition to
his claim frederick cook a man who
accompanied them on henson's first trip
to the arctic as the team's surgeon he
also claimed to have reached the north
pole and he said that he did it first
this triggered an intense debate over
who was telling the truth if indeed any
of them were whether by choice or by
force matthew henson mostly stayed out
of the controversy although he
disbelieved cook's story feeling that he
was too soft to succeed in such a
grueling mission as far as henson was
concerned he lived a quiet unassuming
life after his arctic days were over he
never tried to go on another mission
both because he did not want to do it
without his long-term companion and
because he felt that he'd already
accomplished what he set out to do in
the arctic henson found a job with the
u.s customs house in new york city on
recommendation from president teddy
roosevelt himself and he spent almost 30
years working there he had married again
to a woman named lucy ross in 1907 and
had an inuit concubine named akantinwa
while in greenland who gave him his only
biological child a son named anaok this
fact however was not publicized until
the 1950s after henson's death
unfortunately in the decades following
his historic trip to the north pole
matthiensen saw his accomplishments
swept under the rug and forgotten while
his former partner was made an admiral
and received multiple medals and honors
it wasn't until 1937 that henson was
made an honorary member of the explorers
club of new york and a decade later he
received a medal by the u.s navy for his
efforts mathienson's final tribute in
his lifetime came in 1954 when president
dwight eisenhower invited him to the
white house to receive a special
commendation for his work as an explorer
matthienson died a year later on march 9
1955 in the bronx age 88 in 1988
following a special exception granted by
president ronald reagan matthew henson
and his wife lucy were re-buried at the
arlington national cemetery with full
military honours the image showed henson
and the four men who accompanied him to
the frozen edge of the earth thus some
long deserved recognition was finally
granted to five intrepid explorers who
persevered and triumphed in the face of
adversity both from mother nature and
their fellow men
[Music]